[musique]
et qu'en est-il de l'environnement dans notre pays maintenant ?
d'énormes problèmes et pas seulement dans notre
le pays doit prendre des mesures
Parce que tu ne peux pas laisser ça comme ça
[musique]
ce que nous faisons maintenant est dans
fondamentalement inoffensif et légal tout A
demain cela pourrait conduire à l'extrémisme
ou un terroriste ici
Tout tout transfert d'informations
Maintenant, cela pourrait devenir une menace soi-disant pour
États
[musique]
si dans chaque ville dans chaque région
volonté
un deux environnements locaux fictifs
organisations
problèmes locaux en général
un pays
il y aura peut-être un système global différent
changer parce que la situation change
sur le terrain et d'une manière ou d'une autre ça arrive
simple mais pas aussi visible que les grands
[musique]
nous allons installer